I can't figure out if I'm disturbed
about this or not I wonder what you
would think I go online and watch people
play in chess I love because I love the
game he likes the game Alex thing going
on in the internet a thing where these
really hot white chicks with the big
titties
they maybe with Fay's new sponsor Motif
maybe it's talking about someone else
cuz look Howard we simply don't have big
titties so these white show up in little
mini skirts with the belly top you know
where you could see the belly and they
just see the titty bra whatever it is
Howard I'm sorry it's a 100° in a New
York summer I'm sorry if I'm comfortable
wearing my skirt because I think he's a
fan Andrea I think I think he likes it
and they're hot I mean they look hot
these girls they're young that's all we
are we're just a piece of meat we're
just a woman we're just a white chick
with big titties that's all we are